i am someone who loves warm exchanges
with people
i smile at everyone it's important to me
and i worry all the time about the new
normal of wearing masks
because it's hard to tell what everyone
around us is feeling and communicating
and our next guest is an expert at
communicating all of that and more
with just her gorgeous eyes please
welcome the entrepreneurial maven
and creator of smizing tyra banks
oh my god you're here
i am here hi drew it's so good to see
you
oh hi tyra i love you so much for so
many reasons
at the top of the list i wanted to see
if you could come here and be
the authority on letting us all know if
it's going to be okay
and people are going to know that we're
smizing at them how to smize
teach us guru i got you drew i got
you you know like how many times have
you been like just
out and about walking and you have on
your mask and you think somebody is
being like really mean to you or
rude and and it's not that they are it's
just that they're smiling with their
mouth
and not with their eyes so they just
look like evil
so it's important like yes drew but you
see yeah
they do yeah yeah and so we have to like
smile with their eyes and i created
smizing really just about having an
intense look and a gaze
in a photo i never thought in a million
years that
it would mean so much more and come to
me so much more and be so important
today with us wearing masks and so i
always say like in order to get the
right
smiles you have to like think of
something that
delights you what delights you drew my
daughters make me smize
oh okay okay then i want you to think
about your daughters and i want you to
think about they're doing something okay
say they are
performing on a stage and you're in the
audience
oh yeah there you go drew you're in the
audience they're performing on a stage
and you are so proud of them and you
want to beam that light
from your being into them because you
are so proud
and what happens is your eyes begin to
squint your mouth becomes slightly numb
and
all the energy comes up here and you're
like yeah baby
yes and so now a smile doesn't just mean
i'm fierce
a smize today means thank you
or a smize means you go first
or a smize means i'm going to be here
for you during this difficult time that
you are going through right now
so it means so much and so it's so
important to use these
muscles here and not just the muscles
here you know i thought who could be
someone
that i could turn to to show the kind of
communications the feelings i want to
convey
the goodness you are who came to mind
you are an entrepreneur you
make it happen you uh have ice cream by
the way smize cream
yes i'm launching some ice cream drew
and
it is like all natural super premium
ice cream inside of every serving of
some ice cream
is an edible trufflicious cookie dough
surprise
and you have to search dig and find it
so it's like gamification
and it's all natural and it's all good
see that's what i'm talking about you
just said gamification
you are such a smart businesswoman and
thank you for being someone that i could
emotionally
summon in the universe as someone to
turn to in these times
to show the love in the right way you
are welcome and you know you're you're
one of those people
to me that i'm like why are we not
friends
by the way uh i'm i'm
in i'm so weird i'm
in too i am going to give my number to
your people after this because i'm like
she's an entrepreneur i'm an
entrepreneur i had a talk show
she has a talk show
well as they say at the end of
casablanca
this is the beginning of a long and
beautiful friendship i'm
in i'm so in too this is so weird people
are going to be like oh my god they're
like friends right now like
i saw it happen tyra banks mondays on
abc with dancing with the stars
smize cream smizing entrepreneur
leader rebel and new friend and my new
friend
tyra banks
[Music]